- So your new show is about you going home
to Louisiana, right?
So was that a weird thing?
'Cause it's been a couple years, right?
- Yeah, it was two years
before I had went back
for the show, so a really long time.
It was like, right when I moved out here,
I hadn't gone back since, so...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's super cool.
So did you get to celebrate
Mardi Gras back home?
Did you...
- Oh, I love Mardi Gras.
- 'Cause now you're 21, right?
- I know, I'm 21.
- You can enjoy Mardi Gras.
- You're right.
(both giggling)
I no, I haven't been back from Mardi Gras.
My mom is there right
now and she was like,
sending me pictures and
videos of my brothers,
like, hanging on the fences and beads
and there's thongs and
bras, like everywhere.
- Just to explain, Denmark,
(Kelly and guest laughing)
have you ever been to Mardi Gras?
- I was there just after
and I saw beads hanging from every tree.
I did not understand anything.
- Then you missed the show.
Yes, it's quite a show.
- It's crazy
- It's quite an experience if you ever go.
I've been once.
- Really?
- Yes.
- It's so fun.
- [Kelly] And it's, yeah.
I was like, I don't have any beads, mom.
But nice job, God.
(audience and guests laughing)
I was like, what was
your first visit like?
- Oh my gosh.
My first time in Mardi Gras?
- Yeah.
- So crazy.
I remember it, like I said,
bras, panties, like,
people shirtless on floats.
Like, that's the normal
thing in Mardi Gras.
So it's really crazy.
There's like, I mean now that I'm 21,
I feel like it'd be even more fun.
But really crazy and
just so like, spirited.
I don't know, everyone's
like family back home
in Louisiana.
So, like, everyone's just like
all there to have a good time,
catch beads,
kind of unsanitary, now
that I think about it but...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Guest] But fun.
- The Covid police would frown.
- Right, the Covid police would hate us.
(Kelly laughing)